buenas noches
es un gusto pueden estar aquí monto
ustedes
bueno antes de empezar esta intervención
musical
quiero empezar desde el principio desde
el inicio
desde el comienzo de todo
en una breve reseña
y bueno quiero invitarlos a que pensemos
a que recordemos cuando éramos pequeños
cuando éramos niños y en su momento nos
preguntaron que queríamos ser de grande
desde muchos habrán dicho abogados
arquitectos bomberos doctores
veterinarios y odontólogos
y bueno a lo mejor han dicho también
músicos artistas pintores
bailarines
y desde su comienzo cuando estamos
pequeños siempre
somos aplaudidos admirados y excelentes
que vienen los padres que apoyan siempre
están ahí y bueno ellos te llevan a
estos cursos de danza de teatro de
música y te van diciendo que te apoyan
te dan todo tengo para el estreñimiento
lo que sea y esta es a esa cuestión de
gran apoyo que tienen los padres a un
comienzo
pero qué pasa cuando vas creciendo
qué pasa cuando ya la cuestión cambio ya
está a punto de salir del colegio
en cambio la situación cuando es lo
mismo ahora el padre está preguntando
qué vas a hacer de grande ahora si lo
pregunta ahora si lo hace con mucho
énfasis sentémonos hijo hija y dime qué
vas a ser de grande y todos apoyo qué
pasó en ese momento verdad bueno las
cosas van cambiando y esto no está lejos
de una realidad a mí me pasó
recuerdo que mi mamá me compro una
guitarra cuando yo era muy joven muy
niño yo empecé en el mundo de la música
con aprendiendo música popular con un
gran maestro que ore de año bonito
miranda a quien admiro mucho
y bueno en sus comienzos a todo fue
lindo pero llega un momento llega
incluso tu propia familia que dice
porque está en el instrumento se va a
ser diego se va a perder en el mundo va
a tener muchas mujeres bueno que se
vuelva realidad de eso más bien te
desmotiva y eso contamina incluso a tu
madre a tu padre que se apoyó en un
principio
estoy llena de desilusiones estas frases
como te morirás de hambre eso no es una
profesión eso no te da de comer que vas
hacer y eso entra dentro pero en todos
por familia en tu propia casa
eso es realmente te llega te impacta
porque en realidad
tuve unos pensaste con este arte con
este lindo arte y aprovecha hasta el
momento estuviste aprendiendo mucho
realmente
pero ese momento que te dicen a dónde
vas a parar
es bastante complicada y bastante duro
pero es que en la sociedad que nosotros
vivimos lamentablemente en muchas
ocasiones termina siendo esta una
realidad pues hay que pensar mucho en lo
que queremos ser
sobre todo porque el músico en la
actualidad o el artista en la actualidad
es sobrevalorada
a veces no se le da la oportunidad de
salida al espacio
y esas cosas llegan y piensan que el
músico no es un profesional con la
realidad es lo contrario si yo estoy
parado aquí es porque yo me he preparado
yo me he esforzado yo he luchado y a
veces de lucha basta con mi propia
familia y es así yo tengo mi vida yo
tengo mi responsabilidad y yo quise está
esta vida de artista es dura sigue muy
dura en realidad
pero es lo que me apasiona es lo que
corre por mis venas es lo que soy
quiero ver este
dónde está mi mamá que al ser la mano no
está ya está mi hermana y calzado mano
no está el eje la entrada en la mesa
porque tenía un compromiso tenemos la
quinceañera hoy
y es así cada uno tiene su vida cada uno
tiene su espacio tiene su instancia mi
familia tiene su vida yo tengo mi vida
yo escogí esto yo quiero hacer esto y no
solamente por mí
sino por una esperanza más porque yo sé
que detrás de mí vienen muchos no quiero
ser un ejemplo no sé un ejemplo nada ni
de nadie simplemente me gusta hacer las
cosas bien y si alguien cree que lo que
yo hago está bien quiere seguirme pues
bienvenido excelente yo lo apoyo yo le
doy mi mano yo le extiendo mi
conocimientos a aquellos que han querido
en todo este tiempo
y eso de encajar en la sociedad pues
también no me llegan absolutamente en
nada porque como le dije en antes es mi
vida y explicitación y nada ni nadie va
a detener eso
y es duro si yo lo vivido lo sé pero
créame cada vez que voy avanzando me
encuentro con situaciones muy
halagadoras y todo ese recorrido que he
tenido todos esos problemas los en casa
mismo todas esas situaciones que ocurren
dentro de nuestro propio núcleo pues me
han llevado y ahora estoy aquí ante
ustedes en esta gran plataforma lo que
es tener algo que nunca me había
imaginado en mi vida que iba a pasar y
ha pasado y por qué ha pasado
porque yo le buscaba porque me lo he
ganado
así que
a veces
hay que pensar un poquito hay que
valorar un poco más al artista hay que
entender que en cada artista hay una
historia hay una vida hay algo que va a
impactar porque me es fácil estar aquí
parado no es fácil lo que nosotros
hacemos nos ponemos la camisa por si a
mí me ha pasado muchas veces me he
comido la camisa
el artista se muere de hambre pues la
verdad es que no me ha pasado eso es más
he comido en restaurantes bueno me han
llevado me han invitado y yo muy
gustosamente a restaurantes donde te
cobran hasta por el aire
pero noche estuvo una carpita comiendo y
me da igual que yo vaya que yo esté para
mí siempre va a ser algo especial un
momento único que hay que vivirlo y hay
que disfrutarlo
siempre he dicho que el músico el
artista es una persona muy humanista
porque en su música da un mensaje cuando
el mensaje es bueno llega el mensaje
debe ser bien positivo muchas veces de
estos artistas han hecho llorar al
público han hecho reír al público porque
el músico el artista en sí siente sabe
lo que es el dolor saben lo que es el
llanto sabe lo que es la risa saben lo
que es vivir momentos duros y los
plasman en su pintura lo plasma en su
teatro lo plasma en sus notas musicales
hoy quiero presentarles a estos pequeños
parte de la orquesta de cámara antonio
vivaldi un proyecto que inicié hace un
par de años y bueno a mí me encanta
mucho trabajar con estos pequeños que
diez días se enfoca en nuestra
de lo mejor
qué sé yo de todo este complemento a la
mano el 10% decía ser artista o no y tal
vez eso es relevante lo importante es lo
que nosotros le enseñamos a nuestros
pequeños lo que le enseñamos a nuestro a
nuestros niños para que luego crezcan y
sean personas de bien sea personas que
entiendan a la humanidad que lleguen a
ellos que le den la mano es lo que
realmente hay que enfocarse y hay que
llegar
es lo más importante
y bueno vamos a presentar un temita de
venir a dávalos el tema se llama ángel
de luz
y bueno espero que lo puedan disfrutar
[Música]
bien
y añade
tengo
e
[Música]
[Aplausos]
d